(whoops)
Yes! Thank you very much!
Welcome to the show!
AUDIENCE (chanting):
Larry! Larry! Larry!
-Thank you so much.
-(chanting continues)
Please have a seat.
-Oh, thank you.
-Larry! Larry!
-Good to be back!
-Larry! Larry! Larry!
-Please! Please have a seat.
-Larry! Larry! Larry! Larry
Thank you.
Welcome to The Nightly Show.
I am Larry Wilmore
as they are saying.
(laughter)
Yes, man.
So... Whew!
After the exhausting drama
of the Republican
and Democratic conventions,
The Nightly Show went on break
last week,
and so, it seems,
did Donald Trump's goddamn mind.
(laughter)
Right? Man.
I mean, the man packed
so much crazy into one week
that our show tonight
will be four hours. Um...
(laughter, whooping)
Someone tell Hardwick
we're going long, baby!
(laughter)
So let's get started.
Time for the Unblackening.
♪ ♪
(screaming)
(both screaming)
(Trump screaming)
All right there.
That's a nice...
-The nice compact version of
that is very nice. -(laughter)
So Trump started his week
by criticizing
the Muslim family
of a U.S. war hero.
He then doubled down
on his insults.
And he then KFC
doubled down on his insults.
(laughter)
Seriously, guys, eating KFC
With a knife and fork is no way
to honor
a fallen American colonel.
-(laughter)
-I said it.
I said it. I said it, okay?
(applause and cheering)
Yeah. Thank you.
And... and as if offensive
comments and petty tweets
about the Khan family
didn't show enough disrespect
for our military,
just look
what happened on Tuesday
when he got this fun new gadget.
During a rally
in Virginia yesterday,
Trump said that he was handed
a Purple Heart
from a retired officer
who supported him.
I said, man, that's like...
that's like big stuff.
I always wanted
to get the Purple Heart.
This was much easier.
(audience groaning)
"This was much easier"?
Donald, a Purple Heart is
the highest honor bestowed
to those are who were wounded or
killed when serving our country.
It isn't some toy prize you get
in a McDonald's happy meal.
(laughter)
Nor... nor is it
the literal purple heart
of beloved McDonald's character
Grimace.
-(laughter, applause)
-Right?
(groaning)
Still, after stealing
this Purple Heart,
the GOP's Hamburglar went after
one of our nation's
most famous
Purple Heart recipients.
You know, never been
a big fan of John McCain,
and, uh, I just hate the way
our veterans have been treated
by John and other people.
Okay. (sighs)
He thinks "five and a half years
a POW" John McCain...
is the person disrespecting
veterans right now.
You know what?
(stammering):
That... I...
(laughter)
-(woman whoops)
-I've run out of words
to call this fool an idiot
or to call this idiot a fool.
I... I can't...
You know, here you go.
To help me out, guys, we have
a couple of U.S. veterans
on our staff here
for a new segment,
Veterans Who Work
at The Nightly Show
Respond to Donald Trump's
Disrespect of the Military
Because Larry's
Run Out of Words--
Benari Poulten
and Jonathan Ginter!
(applause, cheering, whooping)
Ah, very good.
So, uh...
(applause, cheering,
whooping continue)
Uh, by the way, guys, thank you
for your service, by the way.
And I wonder
if you can help me out.
Um, I've just run out of words.
-No problem, Larry. We got this.
-(military drumbeat playing)
It is with honor that we bestow
this special commendation
upon Donald Trump.
(fifes and drums playing)
(cheering, whooping, applause)
Thanks, guys. Benari Poulten
and Jonathan Ginter, everybody.
(applause)
Of course,
last week Donald Trump's grudge
against John McCain
led him to hold his endorsement
for the Arizona senator,
as well as Paul Ryan.
But after getting
a stern talking to
from RNC detention room monitor
Reince Priebus...
-(laughter)
-(exhales) Trump came around.
I support...
and endorse...
our speaker of the house,
-(cheering)
-Paul Ryan.
And while I'm at it...
I hold in the highest esteem...
Senator John McCain.
(laughter)
Honey, I... love you.
We...
we will be together...
forever.
Wife.
(laughter, applause, whooping)
(mumbling inaudibly)
I'll tell you guys,
it's hard to tell
when he seems the most crazy--
when he's reading from a script
or when he goes off of it,
right?
Here he is, expertly displaying
his non-grasp of foreign policy
and geography
when asked about Putin.
He's not going into Ukraine.
Okay? Just so you understand.
He's not gonna go into Ukraine,
all right?
You can mark it down,
you can put it down, you can...
-Well, he's already there,
isn't he? -Okay.
Well, he's there in a certain
way, but I'm not there yet.
(laughter)
You're not there yet?
Where is there,
a basic level of intelligence
and awareness of the world?
You don't... you don't need
security clearance
to know this (bleep).
You just need the newspaper,
and not even a good one.
-You could...
-(laughter)
-Sorry.
-(applause, whooping)
I don't know.
That's right. But you could.
You could stay at a Days Inn
and induce it from the pictures
in a USA Today.
Come on! Come on!
All right, guys, so after
an historically awful week,
Donald Trump has dropped
precipitously in the polls,
and his media surrogates
have a lot to explain.
But they always manage to avoid
actually explaining anything.
This is not what we should be
talking about right now, Victor.
We should be talking
about Hillary Clinton.
The issue is not Mr. Khan
and, uh, Donald Trump.
The issue really is, uh,
you know, radical jiham...
radical Islamic jihad...
Do you believe
this election could be rigged?
I think what he's talking about
is the very unfair media
coverage that Republicans get.
See how they did that?
-(laughter)
-This is what happens
when you drink
the Trump Kool-Aid-- it...
-(laughter)
-No. It's true.
It's like if
you're in the position
of having to defend
Jeffrey Dahmer, right?
It's, like, "Okay, did Jeffrey
Dahmer eat those people?"
"You're asking me
if it's fair to judge people
-"based on an eating disorder?
-(laughter)
I don't think you want me
to answer that."
(exhales)
In other words,
Trump surrogates, your candidate
is a cannibal and
should not be in charge
of running the country,
all right?
So, to help us unpack this is
Trump's chief media strategist
and on-air communications
coordinator, Stephanie Spencer.
(cheers and applause)
Okay, all right, so, Stephanie,
let me ask you
a very direct question.
Why isn't Trump better informed
on foreign policy?
If what you're asking me is why
the Clinton-Obama foreign policy
is so horrible,
I think the American people
want an answer to that, as well.
Okay, no, no, no, no.
Okay, see, no, no, no.
See, you just did it.
See, that wasn't
what I was asking.
You-you just changed
the question.
I'm not gonna let you
get away with this.
Just answer this
simple question:
why isn't Trump better informed
on foreign policy?
Just so we're on the same page,
your question to me is...
Go ahead.
-Why...
-Yes.
-isn't...
crooked Hillary Clinton
answering questions
about her e-mails?
I agree with Bernie Sanders.
We need to know more
about her damn e-mails.
No, you didn't hear that right.
I think you just refuse
to answer anything...
November!
(laughter)
November? What?
Well, you just asked,
when will Donald Trump
win this election
in a historic landslide?
I didn't just ask that!
I never said tha...
that's not even close
to what I said!
I completely agree, Larry!
We're on the same page.
What happened in Benghazi
was a tragedy,
and Hillary Clinton still
has not answered for it.
I never said that.
This is so frustrating.
Oh, no...
let me try this.
Your candidate is such
an enormously undisciplined
(bleep) show, that you can't
even engage in simple, human,
back-and-forth communication
because to do so would probably
lead to you having to admit
that there is absolutely
no reason anyone should vote
for Donald Trump.
100%!
I'm glad we're seeing eye to eye
on this, Larry.
Wait, you actually agree
with me?
Yes, just like you said,
Donald Trump is the only
candidate in-in this race who
will make America great again!
-I never said that.
-January!
Stop it!
Stephanie Spencer, everyone.
We'll be right back.
You can't answer a question!